hi chris hey how you doing
i'm doing great uh congratulations on
this movie people are loving it they're
calling it the funniest one in the mcu
the best thor film do you feel relieved
or did you know that this movie was
going to affect people this much
oh you did both you know the first time
i read the script i thought this was the
best thing i've read and it's going to
be a riot and the funnest experience um
you make the film and then did you just
full of nerves and anxiety as to whether
you know we found it funny we found it
emotional is anyone else going to feel
that way and then yeah to have that
response that we've had is um
is always a relief yeah it's always a
you know a big thankful gratitude-filled
moment i bet did you know though that
people would
i don't know i guess the word is uh they
can't stop talking about naked thor
scene
did you know that that was like
obsessed i thought it would come up you
know
i mean it was always my goal the first
time i played thor in my shirt off and
you know the the north star was one day
it's all going to come off and then here
we are built for that moment and if i
ever did another one
i don't know we can't take anything up
off so that's true it might be just
fully clothed entire film which would be
shocking it's true it's like all
downhill after this it's all downhill
okay so look we've seen thor have his
bromance with star-lord and his romance
with jane foster uh how rewarding does
it feel to work with natalie portman
again after spending so much time with
chris pratt on set oh fantastic um i
started this journey with natalie 10 11
years ago and and uh to reunite now uh
and have her as as the mighty thor was
was fantastic it brought
so much out of myself and out of
character and and really injected a
different energy into the whole space um
yeah and she did just such an amazing
job you know turned up and embodied the
superhero and all its glory and it was
very personal and it was her own version
feel like
it's mimicking anything else anyone else
had done it felt fresh and unique it's
beautiful yeah
were you surprised that you're all done
up i mean you kind of know what she's
going to look like but then actually
seeing her on set like that you're like
thor thor i like it
it's just exciting you know i knew it
was going to look good i didn't know
what to expect though and then she
turned up and i was like
this is it here we go yeah
um i thought it was pretty cool to learn
that your son tristan actually plays
young thor in the movie what was that
like for you seeing that and watching
that scene it was cool it was uh he does
the running scene in the yeah the
transition
he has i think the best running style
out of all three of us in that in that
segment i actually watched him run his
take then i did my run
and looked at the playback and thought i
could do that again i look terrible i
look old and funky and
i love it
is he nervous at all to do something
like that or is he so used to being on
set with you
i've got three kids and he is the most
like
outrageously
confident little showman um
it's it's
yeah he kind of loves it and
it's scary i'm like you chill out might
not not yet
we'll get there we'll get there i love
it
um how does it feel being one of the
remaining og avengers in the mcu and
being at like the top of your game
ah
it feels great you know i mean
so many levels surprising and like
what's the catch here and then
uh humbling and honored and and thankful
you know um it's and it's the fan base
that these films
have and they have for this character um
you know that none of this exists
without them and um
i just feel
very thankful that we've managed to do
something different and fresh each time
and and and that's the goal if you if it
becomes too familiar for us on set and
the audience get bored it's the same
response and and uh
thankfully to taika waititi and even the
russo brothers i mean every every
director i've worked with playing this
character has
asked for and brought something
different out and um if we can keep
doing that i think we're on the right
track
that's amazing well congratulations on
the movie it's um it's like outrageous
and funny and entertaining and heartfelt
it's like everything you want oh thank
you so much yeah thank you
you